here's a guy right here from uh from
high street pub ready
yoho what is going on guys my name is
louis i'm coming from
oxford in england and i'm standing
outside of the eagle
and child's pub one of the oldest pubs
in the country now this is where tolkien
wrote a lot of the lord of the rings
books wow then he would tell
the stories to his oxford university
students
and right across the road there we've
got oxford university which is where a
lot of the harry potter films
were filmed so my question to you is are
we saying lord
or harry potter we're going gandolf or
dumbledore
dobby
well done louis um he also said that pub
is the eagle and child pub a drinking
house where
jrr token uh would write a lot of the
lord of the rings books
yeah that's what he said in the video oh
and then read aloud to his oxford
university student sorry if you said
that
yeah that's what i said my bad he's got
you listening
i don't know that's good in english yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it gives you an american accent for us
the eagle and the child it says huh very
i'm not a big uh harry potter fan are
you that's more
i kind of missed that lola rings was
dope too long for my liking though
it's in the theater for a hot four hours
whatever the [ __ ] it was
question which one do i like the hobbits
and the big feet
yeah ah i like hermione dude
hermione though hermione oh i'll put it
in
her hiney yeah i'll put it in here and
then and then rudy was also a lord of
the rings rudy
is a but that's about notre dame yeah
but rudy
turned into a hobbit oh he is in it oh
talking about that emma watts
yeah rudy's in uh lord of the rings uh
sean
sean austin sean aston talks mental
health
yeah he was a legend dude and if he did
rudy and then he did dang that
i'm going with that you would think
those boys got paid right but we had one
of the hobbits on the
on my show before and he was saying they
knew it was going to be huge
so when they signed the contracts they
tied him in for like all the
oh and they're like you're only getting
this we know it's going to be big we can
hire anybody
so you you're getting this much every
every movie
so because i was like damn you said you
got that [ __ ] you hobbit money he's like
no i don't
then it was gonna be big off the jump oh
that's so they signed us to a low deal
oh that's depressing man
it's just depressing people just taking
advantage of people at every turn you
know and just because they're small
hobbits you know yeah that's ridiculous
because they're small hobbits
there you go i love you i always have
yeah i always have
now i'm going to say what was the man
asking about which one harry potter or
lord of the rings
well the rings all goddamn day i'm a
grown man i'm switching i'm gonna go
harry potter man
that's fair you know i want to see that
dumbledore that gryffindor
what's that game they play that freeze
tag on twitter six
quidditch bro dude you would have been a
you'd have been a
keeper in quidditch you better get a
thick broom for me
[Laughter]
dude what about thick broom bite club
our thick boy broom club
[Music]